si así es raúl buenos días como
comentabas la justicia europea ha
dictaminado que polonia debe pagar un
millón de euros de multa una sanción que
se produce porque polonia se ha negado a
suspender el régimen disciplinario de
los jueces la justicia europea dictaminó
el pasado julio que se suspendiera esta
sala disciplinaria de jueces del
tribunal supremo- que básicamente lo que
hace es que en esta sala se pueda
castigar a jueces que hacen un abuso de
poder o bien no cumplen correctamente el
bien las leyes lo que pasa que la
justicia europea y la comisión europea
lo que sospechan es que en realidad se
trata de una sala que pueda purgar a
jueces que no sean afines al gobierno
ultraderechista de polonia por ello se
exige esta multa que la comisión europea
tiene que velar y ejecutar por lo tanto
será la comisión europea la que pida a
polonia que pague este dinero cada día
porque según la justicia europea es
necesario hacer esta medida porque sé se
pone en entredicho el estado de derecho
y se puede haber o puede haber un daño
irreparable y muy grave en el país si no
se toman medidas